[Music]
foreign
cancellation today we must cancel a
woman named Kelsey ballerini who I'm
told is a country star I know nothing
about her music but I do know everything
I need to know about her personally
based on a conversation she recently had
during an episode of a podcast called
tell me about it with Jade Iovine now as
reported by the daily wire ballerina
spent uh ballerini rather spent sometime
during the interview explaining her
reasons for divorcing her husband singer
Morgan Evans and they just got divorced
after five years of marriage now the
brief clip of this exchange which we
will play for you now
could be an extremely valuable tool
especially for young couples okay in
fact young people in dating
relationships they ask me all the time
how they can know if they've selected
the right partner for marriage right
that's the big question well here's one
way this is a good litmus test sit your
girlfriend down or your boyfriend down
play the following clip for them and
then ask if they agree with the
attitudes and perspectives they hear in
it
and if the answer is anything but oh
hell no are you kidding me
run don't walk run in the other
direction and never look back
so with that setup here it is
is this person right for me like am I
good with this being forever is am I
good with him never doing the dishes
ever in my life you know for the rest of
my life or whatever those stupid things
are how did you know that it wasn't
relationship anxiety or negative
intrusive voices in your head and that
it was actually like your heart speaking
that's a good question
I'm really like intuitive and in tune
with myself and like my gut and my heart
and I think for a while you're right it
was kind of like okay this is just a new
phase of a relationship because
relationships go through Seasons right
and like yes it's not always going to be
rainbows and butterflies like that's
just not it and I and I think for a long
time
I I was like oh this is just
the glitter wears off that's what
happens you know and then you just you
get into a phase where you just you wait
for you wait for it to come back and
then
you know and then sometimes it doesn't
but at the end of the day it is such a
disservice and a dishonoring of yourself
if you know something is not right and
you stay but your life is so loud you
know you have so much going on all the
time
I think when people hear about couples
counseling than they hear about a couple
getting divorced they're like oh it
didn't work but oftentimes that is
actually couples counseling working you
know but like because it you realize
that like this was this isn't the
relationship for both of you and I think
what's so hard is having to break your
own heart and someone else's in the
process of saving yourself
so hard
okay so the glitter wore off after five
years and then uh Kelsey patient woman
that she is waited around for a phase to
see if the glitter returned but to her
horror it never did she must have spent
hours maybe even days potentially a week
waiting to see if the magical marriage
glitter would fall from the sky but it
didn't and she doesn't want to be in a
non-glittery marriage who would uh
indeed she says that it would be
dishonoring and a disservice to herself
if she were to honor her marriage vows
and remain loyal to the man that she
pledged her undying love and Devotion to
but who cares about things like vows and
Oaths and everything else I mean think
about the glitter that's what matters
so she got up and left of course the
other woman in the exchange Jade fully
understands and agrees with this
approach to the marriage Sacrament in
fact she adds that um this is one of the
great benefits of marriage counseling is
that so often as she explains it can
help you to understand that you need to
leave your spouse
after all if you aren't happy then what
else is there to do you just have to
leave
do one more glitter check before you
head out the door stop for a moment look
around do you see any glitter no well
then that's it time to go
like I said play that clip for the PIP
the person you're dating if they roll
their eyes and scoff and say something
like who are these dumb bimbos you know
you found yourself a keeper but if they
listen intently and nod their heads and
say wow yeah glitter in the marriage
that makes some good points
promptly get up
inform the person the relationship is
over and just leave no need for a long
emotional conversation simply end it now
before this person ruins your life
because they will
now here's the issue with um
the marital insights offered by Kelsey
and Jade well there are many issues but
it's a Friday I don't want to be here
all day so let's uh we'll boil down to
just a few
what we heard In that clip is is the
very common and very wrong uh passive
view of marriage and romance it's the
idea
that your relationship with your spouse
is fueled by some sort of mysterious
emotional Force which is often
incorrectly called love and that as soon
as your marriage runs out of this
mystical fuel all you can do is abandon
it on the side of the road and hitch a
ride with the next car that happens to
drive by
this view is popular in our society
because it removes all responsibility
and all blame from the individual
marriage is presented as a passive
Endeavor it's something that's
established something that's uh and then
destroyed by forces outside of our
control
love is something that you fall into
right like a puddle and then out of and
there's not much you can really do to
call it to cause the one to prevent the
other
we chalk it up to irreconcilable
differences it's all just stuff that
happens oops I'm married oops I'm having
an affair oops I'm divorced oops I'm
married again oops I'm divorced again
oops I'm lonely isolated and everyone
I've ever known resents me oops silly me
I'm so clumsy
but here's the reality these were
choices every step of the way and
state which you find yourself in
falling in and out of this is not love
because Real Love is an act of will it's
a decision it's a conscious activity
it's something that you do
it's something that you live
okay love is chosen
and if it's protected and nurtured it
grows love is sacrifice love is effort
Love is Everything Saint Paul describes
in First Corinthians love is dying to
yourself love is is many things and none
of them happen by accident
but most of all it's a thing you do it
is an activity
so if you stop loving your spouse after
five years it's because you chose to
stop and most likely you never started
the fundamental confusion is that people
think
that emotional infatuation
that they feel for someone that they
first met
is love you know that's what they think
they might even describe this as falling
in love or love at first sight
but infatuation is not love infatuation
actually has almost nothing to do with
love you can be infatuated with somebody
and not love them okay a stalker can be
infatuated with somebody and then kill
them okay I'm not saying that the
infatuation phase is bad I'm simply
saying that it's a phase
um it happens at the very beginning it's
the fuel that's supposed there's a
there's a reason for it it has a it has
a a function and the infatuation phase
it's supposed to help launch the rocket
and get it off the ground but it's not
going to sustain you for the whole
journey or even for any significant part
of it
because infatuation has to give way to
love which isn't to say
that love is less exciting or less
intense or less thrilling quite the
opposite in fact infatuation is fleeting
it's thin it's hormonal
uh love is much realer it's much deeper
it's much more meaningful
I love my wife today
in spite of the Elvis incident after 11
years of marriage in a way that I could
never have loved her when I first met
her I didn't know her when we first met
only thing I knew when we first met is
that she's hot and she has a fun
personality which was more than enough
to be infatuated with okay it doesn't
take much to be infatuated that's and
that's really
especially if you're a guy that's like
all it takes you don't even need the
personality part it's just the first
part is really but that's not love
um so Kelsey when she talks about the
glitter
what she's really describing is the
infatuation phase but it's all she ever
had with her husband and once it died
rather than work towards a truly loving
and self-sacrificial marriage she just
bailed
many such cases
of course the other problem with this
approach aside from the fundamental
misunderstanding about the nature and
meaning of Love is that it's entirely
self-centered if you you know if your
own immediate and uninterrupted
happiness is the focal point of your
marriage it will fail
and there's nothing unique about that
literally any Endeavor will fail if your
immediate and uninterrupted happiness is
the focal point
you will never be able to do anything
worthwhile in Life or achieve anything
of note ever
if you insist that the whole point of
the Enterprise is for you to Simply Be
Happy
okay if the only thing you care about is
your own happiness you will never do
anything worthwhile in your life you
will be a failure you'll be a miserable
failure for your entire life you will
live a pathetic meaningless life and you
will die and nobody will even remember
that you existed if you live
entirely pursuing your own happiness and
nothing else
now the irony is that Kelsey
is is apparently a successful musician
which means that she understands this
point she has certainly had to Wade
through many unhappy moments in order to
have a success in her music career
nobody can achieve anything notable in
any career if their own happiness is
their sole motivation and goal
I don't know anything about her music I
don't know if it's any good or not but I
mean I suspect it's probably not but but
uh but either way you just it's you
can't become a very successful musician
uh without working really hard it's just
impossible
so if if we can see why that would be
the case in a career
why is it so difficult to see how it
would apply to other areas of your life
that that's not to say that happiness is
irrelevant or unimportant in a marriage
it's just to say that marriage
doesn't exist simply to make you happy
that's not the primary function of a
marriage
it's not the primary function of your
spouse
okay it's not your spouse's job to make
you happy every second of the day it's
not anyone's job to do that
there is no one on this Earth who exists
scratch that there is no one who who
exists in the entire universe
and whose only job is to make you happy
that doesn't that's that doesn't exist
anywhere
it's not anyone's job to do that
and so it's not fair to put that burden
on your spouse especially since the sort
of people who expect others to make them
happy all the time are also the sorts of
people who are never happy
which means that you have given your
spouse a literally impossible job
that you will then blame them for
failing to accomplish
all of that is wrong
and if it was just Kelsey ballerini who
had these uh misconceptions about
marriage it wouldn't even be worth
addressing but tragically these
misconceptions are shared by many in our
culture and it's why so many marriages
fail and uh and so many others never
even begin
and that's why it's still worth saying
today unfortunately Kelsey ballerini is
canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
on Monday Godspeed foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]